a movie star rock star and he's one of
the most intriguing celebrities of our
time Jared Leto but thirty years ago he
was just an aspiring actor living in New
York City and only et has Jared Leto's
first ever interview before he was
famous je ared le tio years before his
breakout role on my so-called life Jared
Leto was just your average college
student living in the Big Apple and et's
uncovered this rare and straight up
random interview with 19 year old Leto
from 1990 Jared Leto he just happened to
be outside this NYC Club where et was
doing a story about the country's
hottest dance crazes pena young Jared
had some thoughts my opinion there's a
few different types of dances one
everybody knows about now because
Madonna is called Vogue and I guess
that's kind of that's like a dance she's
just right and I think it's kind of out
of style as far as the club scene is
concerned I think house dancing is
pretty much the kind of dance that
everybody's into it's a real physical
day it's not laid-back or anything you
know it's just uh it's got a lot to do
with a lot of street you know it's like
street dance a lot of kids do it yeah
what's it look like
you should come inside maybe to see what
it looks like you know we'll all be
danced a little later you know they want
it put gotta do a house music hip hop
rap stuff like that you know
so house dancing is the new food I think
hip house you know house dancing
somebody else did something poke strike
during this right here I'm not familiar
with straightener stop those are
probably all just different dance stuff
like there's the running man there's the
hammer
you know MC Hammer kinda took the trade
marking his you know took this little
step and called it the hammer the
running man is just it's kind of old
this guy I would call it out its I don't
know if you want to call out of style
but it's kind of a you know used up
dance step that people used to do a lot
and you see it like on the Palladium or
something that's kind of beat like that
you know but um this is all dance step
old house step I heard the two people
doing the Lambada at a good club in New
York I heard they got the butts kicked I
don't know I don't bother is not
fashionably in dance I would never
consider if a tional en dance but I
would never do it I mean that's like
it's like a dance you have to learn you
know I mean for me dancing is like
having fun you know dancing it's like
comes from yourself you know even moving
naturally something you have to practice
and learn to me isn't isn't my idea of
having a great time you know I want to
do something that's natural and I can
just flow into it takes up too much the
answer room you have to have a partner
you know I dance alone probably 99% of
the time and because I dance all over
the place you know what I mean but the
one body have tits it's too organized
you know I mean I think it's more geared
toward an older crowd and a money-making
dance you know I mean to me I think it's
it's worse than than breakdancing is
right as far as I'm concerned you know
all right listen we're inside we're
gonna do a dance if I look for our
lights come by well catch your house
thank you tragically we never saw Jared
hit the dance floor that night but we're
happy to have found this snapshot of a
Hollywood star in the making J ared L
eto
[Music]